all right everyone and welcome to this
talk about our paper is this correct
let's check
and this is Joint work with Omri Ben
elieza and Hanan Moser and Madu Sudan
all right so so before we actually
discuss what's going to appear in the
paper let me start with the story
perhaps some of you know it
so in 1904 Angela beg proved the
following theorem
that a projection of any measurable set
is still measurable okay this is the
result in measure Theory from the
beginning of the last century
nope
according to to Google Scholar this is
somewhat
was somehow what of an influential paper
it has around three citations
and a small but non-zero fraction of
those citations come prior to the year
1917.
now the reason why I mentioned the year
1917 is because inductive something
interesting happened and
this is the story was susling red
the best paper and found the following
counter example that there exists a
projection of a measurable set which is
not measurable in in other words
sizzling found a mistake
in lebeg's paper okay this is how to
have a somewhat of a happy ending
because it led to the wealth of the
field of descriptive surf Theory and and
many other results but one question
remains what happened with all of those
papers
which relied on the tax paper prior to
1917 in essence they they might have
used a long result
and it could be that lebeck's mistake
propagated forward
Okay so
quantifying the effects of such mistake
is somehow what we aim to do in this
work and and let me now open with a meta
question
which will be the main focus for us
today is no given such a mistake in a
paper or in any knowledge producing
system
what can we do to guarantee that the
effects of a single mistake or what
single error do not propagate forward or
well not that they don't propagate
forward but with their limits their
effects
okay in order to answer this question in
a more precise sense what we do we
Define a model
for the process of accumulating
knowledge so this can be the scientific
process in which you write paper which
build upon other papers this can be more
more related to
um software development where you write
a library which builds upon other
libraries and so on
and any process in which you accumulate
knowledge and what we want
from our knowledge to to represent is to
have
new units of knowledge added to it over
time and each new unit of knowledge will
need to build upon previous existing
units but our model will also have the
ability to introduce error to each new
unit model so some new units of model
will be errones okay but
errors can be checked and rectified
so once there is a checking procedure
which checks for errors in the model and
once an error is found out it can be
removed from the process okay so it's a
sort of a growth and destruction model
between the introduced knowledge and the
remove the rules
and what we focus on is the structural
probabilities of the model for example
the question is do errors propagate
however
okay so so what I'll do now I'll explain
the model
in detail
and after that I hint about some of the
results we obtained for this model
so let's start with an ideal situation
okay ideally we would like to store
knowledge as a director the cyclic
graphs
okay each node represents a unit of
knowledge say a paper
it is represent units of knowledge
building or inheriting from one another
for example when a paper cites another
paper it's a directed a secret graph
because there should be no Cycles in the
citation but every node can cite
multiple other papers
now in order for us to Define such a
model and we would need to define a
proper knowledge of a proper model of
clustering right because
the set of papers the single Paper sites
usually have some similarity between
them and and
well this might lead to a somewhat
untractable analysis
so we decided for now to consider a
simplified notion and represent
knowledge as a tree okay so every paper
cites one major paper instead of several
so okay in our knowledge in our process
knowledge is represented as a tree we
call it the Knowledge Tree
and a node represents a single unit of
knowledge and edges represent the
relation of building upon existing
knowledge
now every node has a has two types of
labels
a hidden label
which is the objective truth written in
that paper or in that you or in that
knowledge those two labels are
conditionally true or true knowledge and
condition will be false or false
knowledge but initially those states are
unknown okay only the public states are
known which is what the public knows
okay so those are the proclaimed two
states for short PT and the proclaimed
for State PF
now a no a note can be wrongful in two
cases either it is conditionally false
objectively the knowledge inside it is
wrong or it builds upon the wrong unit
Okay so
and all these false in those two cases
and in other case it holds true
knowledge which means that all ancestors
up to the root of the three
are conditionally true
but this is a hidden state of course
so so this is the structural properties
of the model and now I'll explain the
Dynamics okay the three processes going
on one is the process of accumulating
knowledge adding new knowledge the
audience of knowledge then there's the
process of introducing errors to the
model and then there's the process of
removing errors from the model so let's
start with the community knowledge all
right so it's a it's an imperative model
at each time T we have a knowledge three
at time T and its Associated labels like
the three we have here at the bottom to
add a new unit of knowledge we generate
a new node
and we choose a random
parent from among all of the proclaimed
true parents okay Pokemon false parents
are essentially out of the game you are
not going to cite a paper which is known
to be wrong
how do you choose a random parent
this is done according to the
preferential attachment model in brief
the more children you have and here we
only consider proclaimed two children
okay the more influential you are and
the more likely you are to
um to spawn new knowledge okay so
basically the higher the degree of a
node is
the more likely it is to be the parent
of the new node
now what are the labels of each given
new node the public node is always
proclaimed to
okay it's assumed to be turned and until
proven otherwise
so that was the process of accumulating
knowledge now what is the process of
introducing error of injecting errors
so recall every every node also has a
hidden state of the objective truth
inside it
either it is conditionally false or
conditionally too so for every new node
we throw a biased coin with induce a
parameter Epsilon and with parameter and
with probability Epsilon the new node
will be conditionally false otherwise
it's conditionally true so in some sense
this parameter Epsilon is the proportion
of tools obviously sorry the proportion
of arrows in our process okay so for
example in this
in this three the new node shows the
root as experiment but turned out to be
a false node it contains some stake in
it okay it is conditionally false
now what is the process in which we
check for errors so every time a new
node is added to the tree
we saw another biased coin this time
with parameter p
and this is the probability that you are
checking
the knowledge you inherit from
okay
so with probability P the node checks
its ancestors
and then with probability one minus P
does nothing now what does it mean to
check
a node checks its ancestors up the tree
it ascends the tree upwards we introduce
another parameter K which is the number
of level a node goes upwards
and if at any point when it traverses
the path up the tree it finds either a
proclaimed false node
which was publicly false or the
conditionally false node which contains
some mistake
then the entire path
from the node to the wrong parent to the
wrong ancestor changes to proclaimed
false okay the entire files
becomes publicly false essentially it is
removed from the tree
right so to summarize what we what uh
what we Define for the process knowledge
is represented by a tree
knowledge is added according to the
preferential attachment model
more influential nodes tend to become
even more influential
errors are introduced randomly when new
knowledge is created
checks are performed again randomly when
new knowledge is introduced
and error correction is done by
proclaiming faulty nodes to be to be
false
so that was our model
and with the three parameters we
introduced Epsilon the proportion of
arrows
P the proportion of no of notes being
checked and K the depth of his check we
call it will Define this model the
Epsilon p k c k p okay ckp stands for
cumulative knowledge process
so now let me discuss a bit about our
results
so let's go back to the original meta
question we had and make precise sense
of 18 hour model right so we asked can
we guarantee that the effects caused by
a single errors do not propagate
so what are the effects caused by a
single level in our model so an error is
represented by a conditionally false
node as the label the hidden label CF
and the propagation of everything which
is caused by that arrow is all the false
nodes which resides in the subtree voted
at that node
now what would it mean to not allow the
animals to propagate or to eliminate at
all and this is the following
observation if at any point in the
process
all descendants of a faulty node
become proclaimed false then the theory
is essentially eliminated right no other
nodes can join that subtree and it is
frozen in time
so that mistake cannot propagate forward
okay so that leads us to the following
definition
if in our model
we look at any conditionally false node
and we look at the sub tree rooted at
that node if we can say that with
probability one almost truly
everything there becomes proclaimed
false
then we will say that the arrow effects
in this model are completely eliminated
right otherwise there is some positive
probability that the errors will
propagate forever up to time Infinity
and then we say that the arrow effect
survive with positive probability and
then now our meta questions become for
which set of parameters Epsilon p and K
okay checking probability level
probability and depth of checks
can we ensure that the arrow effects are
completely eliminated
okay so let's take our first result now
and our first result applies to the role
of the depth it turns out that the depth
plays an essential role
okay our first result shows the depth
matter and that shallow checks will
never suffice to eliminate
air devil effects okay so formally if K
is 2 if you are only going to check two
levels upwards each time then it doesn't
matter what proportion of knowledge you
are going to check for any non-trivial
pay the air of effects will survive with
positive probability okay so there is a
positive probability for some mistake to
propagate forever
and and the idea of the proof is rather
simple
okay we couple the ckp the community of
knowledge process with the branching
process
and because the checks are so shallow
we are able to show that
if you look at a false node
and you look what happens
at the sub to rooted at that node by the
time it is proclaimed false
well we showed it effectively it
generates many new components behind
beneath it
okay so by using a branching process
argument we'll just show that there is
some positive probability of this these
three going up up to time Infinity
right and the conclusion is is very
simple if you want to guarantee that the
arrow effects are completely eliminated
you cannot have checks which are too
shallow if you're going to write a paper
and you want to ensure that no mistakes
propagate too much it is better to check
not only the pay-per-use site and the
pay-per-day side but a few level upwards
as well
now it turns out that this is a unique
probability of very shallow checks
because our next results it identifies a
phase transition for non-shallow checks
with respect to the checking parameter
Peak okay so formally for any k for any
depth of checks which is at least four
and any non-trivial Epsilon okay any
non-trivial proportion of Errors there
exists some threshold
let's call it peanut such that if the
proportion of checks if p is louder than
P naught then we can ensure that arrows
are completely eliminated in The ckp
and otherwise if P the proportion
objects is smaller than that P naught
then the level of effects May survive
with positive probability
and again the conclusion is
if the checking procedure is not too
shallow if you are going to check at
least for level up well there is some
minimal amount of effort you can put in
the model
to guarantee the elimination of variable
effects and now
the proof of this theorem is a bit
involved with many details I'll just
explain a bit
about what we do and and basically the
idea is to reduce everything to a
marketing or rather a sub mounting and
supermarking Analysis we Define
several observable of the process which
we track a long time and we analyze the
Dynamics and we show that in some regime
parameters those observable increase in
expectation of a decrease in expectation
and this allows us to say something
about the long-term Dynamics and some
examples of those
observables are the number of leaves
so for example if we can show that the
number of leaves in expectation goes to
zero
then the three must uh must be
eliminated okay another example is the
distribution of depth
at least for proclaims two nodes okay
how many how many
um Proclaim two nodes do you have at
each level and and then we waited
accordingly so that we can make some
sense of it
um
now
one thing we do is we not only look at
this question of whether
it will survive forever over completely
eliminated but we can also use those
observables to make a somewhat more
refined
um observation and results about the
process
okay so one thing we also look at is you
know how does the train look like when
the Aero effect do survive so you have
some false tree
which goes on forever but we managed to
identify parameters in which it is not
too large it does not occupy uh any any
linear proportion out of the entirety so
and we also control the size of it
actually
okay and another thing we look at when
the arrow effect is completely
eliminated you will always have some
false node simply because the tree keeps
generating false nodes by this parameter
Epsilon because you can ask what is
whenever affects open people I mean how
many false nodes do you actually have
what is the proportion of force nodes
and we show that again there is a set of
parameters in which there are no false
nodes above the noise level above the
parameter Epsilon
and those are in different results let
me just say a bit about future Direction
so the two theorem the two-phase
transition I showed or I discussed with
respect to depth they show that no k
equals 2 that equals 2 is special and
then you have a phase transition with
respect to P when K is at least four
but somehow our analysis misses the case
of what happens when you are only
checking three level apps so that is
interesting to to check
another thing which is interesting to
find out is what is the exact
value of peanuts
in the sales transition okay what is the
minimal amount of effort you need to to
invest in order to ensure that errors
are completely eliminated as a result is
somewhat existential and we give bounds
but we do not know the exact value of P
naught
and maybe a more General future they
reckon is to consider more General
models as we discussed before okay
instead of trees maybe we can consider
directly the cyclic graphs and this will
require us to extend
the preferential attachment model to
direct the simply graph
by also taking care of this clustering
of knowledge we want a new node to
choose a subset of parents which shows
some similarity
and
that's it for today thank you for
listening